[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
as a french almost never say in politics
it's getting hotter in the very week
that our government makes it easier to
visit our neighbours across the channel
a bitter war word breaks out between our
nearest france and our dearest america
the deal to provide nuclear submarines
australia with american technology has
enraged president macron and left the
ontart pretty far from cordial
it all comes at the worst possible
moment for our government as we approach
cop 26 in glasgow the crucial conference
on climate change
if there's a deal to be had someone is
going to have to cool down the
diplomatic temperature and the prime
minister is off to the un in new york to
do his best can he fix it well we'll be
joined by the man he appointed to
deliver the deal on climate change and
we'll hear from a former cia boss and
confidante to not just one but two
presidents
that's assuming the government can keep
the lights on for at least the next hour
amidst a growing concerns and crisis
talks over the uk's energy supplies
joining us today from the government the
minister in charge of the un climate
talks alex sharma
we'll speak to green mp caroline lucas
about what she would do to avoid an
energy crisis this winter
and labour's pat mcfadden accuses the
government of a failure to plan that has
left businesses and consumers
dangerously exposed
we'll speak to one of the government's
scientific advisers about kovid
professor stephen reicher a member of
the sage subcommittee on behavioral
science
former cia boss and u.s defense
secretary leon panetta tells us why he
thinks the french should be more
supportive after washington upended
their biggest defense contract
and in return french diplomat gerard aro
offers the perspective from paris he
says the uk is being run by monty python
and france has been betrayed
but first i'm joined by the president
for cop 26
alok sharma
mr sharma thank you for joining us can
you reassure viewers that the lights are
going to stay on this winter well trevor
thank you for having me on your your
program uh well obviously people reading
what's in the in the press will be
concerned about the supply of of energy
uh the impact on on prices as you all
know the the business secretary has been
having detailed discussions with the
sector this weekend he'll be continuing
those today and it's going to be a round
table tomorrow but i think the the clear
message that is coming out of this is
that
there is no immediate concern in terms
of supply we don't see any risks uh
going into the winter and when it comes
to prices we of course have an energy
price cap there are also mechanisms such
as the warm home discount which are
available to support people as well so
people should be confident
that uh the supplies will be there and
that we will be protecting them in terms
of price rises but of course we're not
complacent about this and that's
precisely why the business actually is
having these very detailed discussions
with the sector i i know you've got to
say all of that but this is sort of um i
know what people are going to be saying
as they're watching oh god there's the
don't panic message from dad's army
now's the moment to panic
we're looking at 70 plus rises in gas
prices um
just at a practical level isn't it a
moment where you could for example
reconsider the cut the 20 20 pounds a
week cut in universal credit
to reassure particularly
uh poor families that they are not going
to have to freeze in their homes this
this winter well i mean let's talk about
firstly the the price issue because
that's a very important one there is a
reason we introduced the energy price
cap it is to protect millions of people
as i said when it comes to it's going to
drive when it comes to flyers out of
business well when it comes
to this business
let me address that issue but when it
comes to supporting those who are on
lower incomes we of course have uh
the warm hymns discount uh winter fuel
payments and other mechanisms in place
so we are there to support people when
it comes to these costs um and actually
you know talking about the supply
significant element of the the gas
supply in the uk is domestic uh where we
have imports they'll be coming from
secure places like norway
and people should feel confident that
this is something that the government of
course is not being complacent about but
they should feel confident that the
supply will be there
but the truth is that
you don't know that
you don't know that
and you can
issue as many rear messages reassurance
as you like but
there might be at least a case for
saying let's
help those families let's at least hold
open the possibility that if prices do
go up you can help those families well
we are helping those families as i said
there is the warm homes discount there
are other payments that are made to
those on lower incomes and of course
we've got the price cap so that support
is is absolutely there and i want to
reassure people that is not going away
and as i said when it comes to supply uh
you know
at this point in time we feel confident
that there is not a risk and of course
of course
this is not about complacency trevor you
you made the point about uh you know
dad's army it certainly isn't that i
mean i'm a dad but uh
just to be clear there's nothing to do
with dad's army this is a really uh
laser-like focus that the business
sector has on this issue and that's why
uh he is convening uh all these these
groups and making sure that actually we
do
uh have a solution longer term to this
and and part of that solution by the way
since we're going to talk about cop part
of that solution part of that solution
is
rolling out more renewables you know in
the last 10 years we've quadrupled the
amount of renewables we have in the
country we've got the biggest offshore
wind sector in the world trevor we want
to quadruple that as well by 2030. but
that's how you take care of energy
security and energy supply is building
out domestically when it comes to
renewables but actually that's it that's
exactly part of the point the the your
shadow or the shadow uh energy secretary
um ed miliband's made the point that
you've been talking about renewables and
all the rest of it for the last 10 years
but you can't be absolutely sure because
you haven't got on with it that we will
have uninterrupted supply because there
just isn't enough that's been generated
by renewables you have an open new
nuclear capacity as you thought as you
said you would well i think i have to
say it's entirely wrong to say that we
haven't built out renewables we've
quadrupled the amount of renewables uh
over the last 10 years and i said we now
have the biggest offshore wind section
in the world and to make this point you
know people talk a lot about coal for
instance back in 2012 trevor 40
of electricity was coming from coal it's
now less than two percent and by the end
of 2024 there will be no more coal in
our electricity mix and the reason is
precisely because we have built a big
renewable sector
will you um
take the opportunity now then to rule
out
a new coal mine
in cumbria which is what is uh on the
cards and which the government has sort
of kicked down the road until
cop after cop 26. why don't you just
tell us no more no more new coal
capacity yeah
well so i think in terms of this coal
miner it's been discussed many times
there is no coal mine at this stage
there's a public inquiry which which is
ongoing right now so i mean i don't want
to comment and say well you don't want
well
capacity there is a reason that uh in
our sort of democratic process is that
we have public inquiries everybody gets
a chance to have their say
and that inquiry is still running so
let's see what comes out of that what
does the the inspector say to that um
but i go back to this point about coal
which is that we act actually are seen
around the world as a poster child when
it comes to a clean energy transition
and we have built the biggest offshore
wind sector in the world there's no
doubt about it i mean you know coal will
be history in 2024 in our electricity
mix but with with respect the very fact
that you cannot say
directly to me you know what we do not
whatever the process is we would rather
not have a new
coal mining uh facility in cumbria on
stream in the next few years the fact
you cannot say that to me will send a
message around the world that actually
though you talk a good game
you don't really do the business trevor
let's see what comes out of the public
inquiry but you know my message i mean
you sort of said that i'm responsible
for this this climate conference my
message is going around the world and
ensuring that we have all countries
committing to phasing out coal in their
energy mix as the uk has done and
actually we are seen as leading in the
world in this issue all right well
you're off to new york this afternoon to
talk to people from around the world
with the prime minister to try i guess
to set up
the deal um
your heart must have sunk this week when
the prime minister and mr biden and mr
morrison announced a new deal and the
french went uh
a bit crazy about it and the chinese
didn't denounce it as irresponsible it's
not the best diplomatic environment is
it to get a deal well look i mean this
is a trilateral deal between three very
close partners this is about the in the
pacific uh and we've been very clear
this isn't about provoking anyone we
want to have good relations with all
countries we want to work with mutual
trust with all countries but in terms of
what in terms of my role whatever you
wanted
in terms of my role trevor what i can
tell you is that i personally have
spoken to world leaders uh ministers and
over a hundred governments and there is
a very unified view on this they do see
climate change as an issue which is a
great leveler
climate change does not respect borders
and countries individually see what is
going on in their own country i mean
you've seen
literally in the last few weeks uh the
horrific flooding that's been in china
in central europe loss of life and
livelihoods you've seen wildfires raging
in in north america record temperatures
in europe this is all down to climate
change and that is why countries
recognize that we need to act
collectively and together and why i am
told by every country that i speak to is
they do want cop 26 to be a success okay
every country um simple answer here
you've got 100 leaders who said they're
coming
has president xi jinping of china said
he's coming
no not yet
but as you know i was in in china
recently i had
constructed but very frank discussions
with china and of course they've made
various commitments on on cutting
emissions on on phasing down the use of
coal and i was very clear i said to them
that we want to see the detailed policy
around this and they along with every
other major economy the g20 have
committed before cop 26 driver to come
forward with uh ambitious plans to cut
emissions um and i have to say to you
that in every conversation i had with
the chinese they were very clear they
were very clear that they want to see
cop26 as a success so the ball is very
much in their court well they're they're
all kind of definitions of success
aren't there china
is mining four billion
uh four million tons of coal a year
uh it is the biggest emitter in the
world
is xi jinping going to turn up and sign
a deal because without china it's all
pretty meaningless isn't it well there's
no doubt that china is going to be part
of the key to all of this absolutely
they're the biggest emitter in the world
and what president xi jinping has said
is that they're going to strictly
restrict the use of coal in this next
five-year period from 2026 they're going
to phase down
but of course we want to see the detail
of that that is what is really important
here as well
and that's what we're pressing them and
i repeat the point they've said to me
they want cop 26 to be a success well
you know the ball is in their court we
want them to come forward and make it a
success together with the rest of the
world talking about detail um
your colleagues in cabinet have
just signed a trade deal with the
australians
in which
they omitted
any specific
numbers in relation to the australians
coal production and emissions uh which
had previously been in the what the
australians signed in the paris accord
now
you say the detailed matters actually
what your government's just done is
taken out the details uh that would have
tied one of the biggest coal producers
in the world to proper targets well
trevor you're right detail actually
matters and this deal has not yet been
signed it's an outline form and the
legal text is being worked on but i just
want to clarify this point that the uk
has some of the strongest environmental
uh uh
uh measures in the world we are not
compromising that in our trade deals and
when it comes to australia but let me
address that point because when it comes
to australia there is absolutely going
to be a substantive clause in that deal
which makes reference to the commitment
of both countries to the paris agreement
and the goals of the paris agreement so
it is going to be there in black and
white are going to be tied to numbers
they are going to be tied to the
commitments that are made in the paris
agreement and the parents agreement is
very clear in terms of uh where we want
to see the limiting in temperature rises
uh in in the world and just to be clear
that uh you know
parliament uh very select companies are
going to have an opportunity to
scrutinize this deal they're already
looking at the outline
when the detailed text is agreed they
will have a chance to scrutinize this so
but i want to be very very very clear on
this point is that we are not
compromising in terms of the
environmental measures that we have in
our country that hard won
as a conservative government i'm really
proud that this is what we are doing and
supporting and of course if you look in
in the in the trade deals that we want
to negotiate we want to talk about how
do we also expand uh
the the the import and export of green
goods for instance the resources
minister of australia said
the reports of cold impending death are
greatly exaggerated and its future is
assured well beyond 2030. that doesn't
sound
like a government that is preparing to
wind down its production of uh
of of
coal well let me make a wider point
about coal which is that if you look at
the the cost of renewables around the
world it is cheaper to install new
renewables in the vast majority of the
world than it is to have coal power
plants if you look at investments in
coal the private sector is increasingly
reluctant to invest in coal because they
can see these are going to become
stranded assets and actually we talked
about china i mean if you look at some
of the statements coming out of some of
the biggest banks in china which do
financing of international coal they've
said that they're going to be setting
out plans to phase down uh that
financing of coal projects uh uh around
the world and i think so we are seeing a
move where coal will become consigned to
history but we do want every country to
step up on this point all right um
you've got
a couple of days in new york to solve
the problem
you must admit that what has happened
this week must have made the
environment the climate for those
negotiations
more difficult the french are furious
with us the americans who knows where
they are uh there is a standoff all
around and the chinese are really being
aggressive on the uh on the american and
british foreign policy your life must be
being made much more difficult than it
needs to be well trevor the last 18
months uh you know and we've had all
sorts of uh you know bilateral matters
multilateral matters that have been
going on over the past 18 months i have
been getting access talking to
governments as i said i've spent over
100 governments personally
and that is because
uh people know that my focus is on
climate
and they all understand the reason we
need to solve this together as i said
you know i'm told by every country that
i meet they want cop 26 to be a success
and we need to hold them to it and what
will success look to look like for you
well it's the numbers that will come out
of cop26 that will be successful well
what we want to do is to ensure that we
are limiting uh a global warming uh in
the paris agreement uh world leaders set
out in 2015 that uh
you know we would seek to limit the
rising global temperatures to well below
two degrees uh aiming for 1.5 degrees
and we want to get to a point where we
can say that we have kept 1.5 alive i
want to make this really a really
important point because we talk as
politicians about
these numbers and lots of people
watching this will say well yeah 1.5
degrees doesn't sound like a lot but
actually currently the world is one
point degree two degrees warmer than
before pre-industrial levels and you are
seeing the impact of that around the
world in our own country you're seeing
an increase in flooding increase in in
rain and that's just going to get worse
rising sea levels that's just going to
get worse and that's why we need to
collectively work and particularly the
biggest emitters to g20 you need to come
forward and set out ambitious plans to
cut emissions alex sharma thank you very
much we'll know that we'll be talking
again at glasgow thank you thank you
okay let's bring in the green mp
caroline lucas who's warned that the
climate talks in glasgow
just got a lot harder
uh good morning carolyn lucas um
you have probably been listening to what
alex sharma has been saying do you
believe him that he's got the makings of
a deal
i think he's doing his best but i think
his efforts at international diplomacy
are being entirely undermined by
government actions at home as you
pointed to in your questioning yourself
the first rule of diplomacy is to walk
your talk and yet both on the finance
for climate and on the emissions
reductions this government is doing the
opposite it is absolutely outrageous
that the government has cut our own aid
budget by 4 billion pounds and yet
thinks it has the moral authority to
lecture other countries about increasing
their climate finance we are in no
position to do that when we have slashed
our own aid budget and when it comes to
emission cuts if you look at what
government is actually doing we are way
off track in terms of meeting our own
climate targets the committee on climate
change the government's independent
advisors says that we keep blundering
into high carbon choices you've got the
cumbria coal mine that you mentioned
you've got a new oil field being planned
uh the cambo oil filled off shetland
you've got a 27 billion pound road
building plan you've got airport
expansion you've got the failure to put
in place any kind of home insulation
program the list goes on and on so in
terms of walking the talk i'm afraid
that alok sharma's very good efforts i'm
sure at diplomacy are being cut off at
the knees by the prime minister
one of the striking things that um mr
sharma
told us is that he has not yet got
an rsvp yes from the chinese president
xi jinping
do you think
that a deal that is sustainable can be
struck without his presence
i think that's almost impossible to
envisage no it is absolutely essential
that china is there and that's why i am
deeply concerned about this new
so-called orcas deal because we have
just
enraged the chinese even more if cop 26
if this climate talks these u.n climate
talks are our top diplomatic priority
then everything else should be taking um
second place to that so i'm deeply
worried about relations with china i'm
also deeply worried about relations with
the developing world because they too
have the ability to walk away from these
talks if they choose to they were
promised a hundred billion dollars a
year
by 2020 they were promised that right
back in 2009 and we still haven't
delivered we are 20 billion short of
that not only that but just two percent
of some countries in africa have been
fully vaccinated so when it comes to
equality we are absolutely okay and
raging as well the developing world
losing their trust as well as losing the
trust of countries like china
let's
let's talk about opinion
at home um
i don't know if you were in invited to
the protests
around the m25
or if you were free but had you been
invited and been free would you have
been out there blocking the road
well trevor i have a proud history of
taking non-violent dire action as does
the green party and we do believe that
it is legitimate when other forms of of
trying to raise issues with the
government have failed as long as it is
non-violent then i think we need to
understand why protesters have taken
this extreme action you know ban ki-moon
the former un general secretary has said
this is an emergency and in emergency
situations we need to take emergency
action i believe that's what those
protesters were doing um it is a really
difficult thing to try to capture on a
mild september sunday the fact that we
are facing an existential threat to life
on earth that feels a very odd thing to
say over your breakfast but that is what
we are facing when it comes to the
demands of those protesters they want
the government to insulate britain i
cannot think of a more reasonable demand
it's a it's a triple win it would get
our fuel bills down it would create
hundreds of thousands of jobs in every
part of the country it will get our
climate emissions down too why has the
government failed to do that
so so um i'm taking that as a yes and
that you think it's reasonable
for this cause
to stop people going to work
particularly those people who can't work
from home do you think that's okay and
you would have been i think it is
i think it is unreasonable for this
government to have no no let's let's
just stick with the protest itself i
know your view about the government you
think it's reasonable for them to have
done what they did
i'm saying that their demands are
reasonable and i'm no well i'm asking
about what they did
it is reasonable to take emergency
action and that's what they were doing
the government has failed to put in
place any kind of um
insulation program first of all we had
the green deal that completely failed it
had interest rates of eight percent so
if people were taking loans to insulate
their homes that would have cost them a
fortune then we had the green homes
grant that has collapsed in absolute
chaos there is no program to keep
people's homes warm in the meantime
what's happening is that people are
dying prematurely every year from fuel
poverty what's happening is that around
15
of our emissions in the uk are coming
from our leaky housing stock what is
unreasonable is the fact that the
government sets its face against a set
of policies that will get our emissions
down that will get jobs up that will get
people's fuel bills down and would
address some of the issues you were
talking to alec about right at the start
of this conversation which was about
prices as well i fully understand your
point about what you regard as a
government iniquities but uh just to be
absolutely clear coming to the end now
you think this was a perfectly
reasonable action uh if they send you an
invitation next time you will be saying
yeah i'll come and i will block the m25
i am saying that in extreme situations
it is reasonable to take extreme actions
and that is what has driven these
protesters to do that personally i
prefer to take action where it is closer
to the target of that action so that
might be downing street it might be the
treasury but i fully understand why
protesters have felt driven to do
something more dramatic than that
because government has been ignoring all
of those kinds of actions for many many
years we face an existential crisis and
emergency and we need to take emergency
action now
thank you caroline lucas
now labour's accused the government of
leaving the country over reliant on
imported gas and this called on
ministers to do more to help families on
low incomes with household bills
forecast to rise by as much as 400
pounds a year pat mcfadden is the shadow
economic secretary to the treasury
uh pat mcfadden the business secretary
is call crisis talks with the suppliers
tomorrow um
if you were sitting in his seats what
would you be asking them to do
well the short term in the long term in
the short term
what the business secretary must do is
ensure continuity of supply that's a
basic duty of government
for both
domestic consumers and for businesses
and we've seen
other ramifications of this over the
last 24-48 hours for example on food
supplies with with co2 being a necessary
byproduct and in the long term what this
has shown
is
the need to get on with the transition
to net zero
and the vulnerability of the reliance on
fossil fuel markets especially
international ones so there are things
that you can't change because the
situation is here and now but this
should act as a spur to get on with the
transition to net zero more renewable
and sustainable supplies because the
effect of all this will be rising prices
for consumers just when they're being
hit with other things too well you're
reassured by what alex sharma said about
the con about the continuity of supply
during this winter well i've seen what
he's said and i've seen what the
business secretary has said uh over the
last 24 hours i hope that's right uh
because continuity supply is essential
as i said um but this really must act as
a spark to
avoid situations like this where
suddenly we're very exposed when there's
an international price spike but what
would you do to make sure that that
doesn't happen because in a sense part
of this is a problem to do with an
unforeseen
event uh that's created a problem in in
the pipelines i mean how would you if
you were in government deal with that
well you'll see that the immediate uh
price bike may be unforeseen but the
reliance on international markets is
foreseen and you can do something about
that by investing in your own storage
capacity by making sure you've got
alternatives to gas and we're going to
have to do this for net zero anyway so
some of this may be unforeseen but a lot
of it should have been foreseen and you
know we can't be surprised by net zero
like somebody being surprised by
christmas uh one year we've got
legislation that says we have to do this
and that means that government has to
have a plan to get there what does part
of labour's plan be to cease
uh the opening of new
fossil fuel streams for example the
cambo oil field in scotland or a new
coal field in cumbria would labor simply
say we're not doing that look
you know on individual plans they have
to be judged
on their merits but the overall
direction of travel has to be less
reliance on fossil fuels because there's
no way to reach our net zero targets
which are shared across the political
parties unless we do that
but uh you're sort of
if i may say so echoing what alex sharma
has said it's not really a decision we
can make now why can't anybody just say
you know what we don't want any more
coal we don't want any more oil we're
basically going to say no to these new
developments because i'm reluctant to
comment on one application i'll give you
two
at a time but certainly the direction of
travel must be that we decrease our
reliance on fossil fuels we increase our
use of renewables let me give you a
great example close to home trevor my
local hospital
new cross of wolverhampton has announced
that they will uh run themselves
completely with their own solar farm
saving 15 to 20 million pounds on energy
bills over the next 20 years all of that
money will go back into front line at
nhs care so i think there's a great
example uh close to my constituency in
the town that i represent which the
government could take a lot of
inspiration from indeed and uh my sky
news colleagues have been uh running
story on that this this morning but i
just let me make one last attempt why
can't labor simply say that there has to
be a compelling emergency case
for a gut the government to agree to
license any new fossil fuel exploitation
well the bar should be high for that uh
and there has to be a you know a very
convincing case given the overall arc of
where we've got to get to on 2030 so i
don't think these things should be uh
approved just on the nod in the way that
they would have been in the past because
that's not the future okay the future is
renewables and sustainable energy and
that's what we've got to get to let's
talk about um your your party um
it's reported today that the mp for
canterbury rosie duffield has said she's
not going to lay party conference
because she doesn't feel
that her safety is assured because of
comments and threats from
activists who object to what she has to
say essentially that uh
biological sex is a fact
the first duty of a government is to
protect its people how can we believe
that labor can be government when it
can't even protect its own mps
well i'd be appalled if rosie thought
that she couldn't go to the labour party
conference oh she's not going yeah i've
seen the article every mp
should be safe uh at labour party
conference or at their own party
conference we had this a few years ago
you may remember with luciano
i was appalled then
and i think first of all
i want rosie to be able to go to
conference but
more broadly here i think there's an
important cultural point about how we
discuss things
difficult issues
have to be able to be discussed in a way
that doesn't result in if someone says
something that someone else disagrees
with
them being placed completely beyond the
pale and subject to
terrible online abuse or threats or
anything like that and we've got to find
a way
to work through issues where people can
say things where someone else might
disagree
uh some of these issues are not easy
without the consequence that you're
talking can we assume that anybody who
is associated with these kinds of
threats uh will not be welcomed
themselves at the labour party
conference if it can be demonstrated
that they either supported tweeted
shared in social media this kind of
abuse of a labour mp
yeah that should be the case and i think
it also underlines
the need for cultural change
uh you know we cannot have this kind of
factionalism uh we can't have this kind
of intolerance
and
you know i'm convinced of the need for
change in the labour party on many
fronts okay but uh the internal culture
is certainly one of them and i would say
that kirsten believes in this very
strongly and he's been very clear about
this since he became leader well i shall
be watching when i attend the labour
party conference myself next week thank
you pat mcfadden
now more than a million people in
england and i should be one of them will
be sent an invitation this week to get a
coronavirus booster jab the health
secretary said that the programme to
provide additional protection to those
aged 50 and over and front-line health
workers would strengthen the wall of
defense well professor stephen reicher
is one of the government scientific
advisors a member of the sage
subcommittee advising ministers on
behavioral science
stephen riker um
your students are returning to uh the
campus that's in andrews this week
it's this week that triggered a fresh
wave last year what um what are you
doing on campus to make sure we don't
have a repetition
well there are multiple measures that
are going on in all universities um
across scotland for instance there's
very clear advice on the need to
keep people safe on the need to have
testing need to have vaccination
very clear messaging on the need to
behave responsibly so you don't put
others at harm so i think at least in
scotland and i can speak for scotland
because i i sit on the recovery group
for universities in scotland um every
university has a very comprehensive plan
about the return um
over the next few weeks although
actually in scotland most people have
already got got back when when you talk
about what's happening um often it's
very anglo-centric and you forget
scotland
i i could never forget scott and
professor reicher but i just want to be
absolutely sure that you feel confident
that we're not going to
have the same problems that we've had in
the past you feel you feel confident
about that at the moment oh i mean
there's huge uncertainty i mean simply
put we don't know what's going to happen
and that's true not just in universities
but more generally as
you know as schools of returning um
they've again they returned a while back
in scotland and we've seen a spike in
infections in young people now the data
is beginning to come through in england
people returning to university people
returning to the workplace people
returning indoors because of uh the wind
with the sorry
i'm getting organized uh because of the
weather um all these are factors and we
can't know absolutely but we uh we have
to be careful
what we do
yeah well we just we discussed all of
those questions actually with the
scottish first minister uh last sunday
and um it's clear that there's a
slightly different point of view you
yourself have been pretty critical of
the government the um
of uh the johnson administration uh for
not underpinning its legal measures
with behavioral
uh science and behavioral nudges um
are you supportive of what they've done
this week on travel restrictions
i think the example of travel
restrictions is an example where we had
a dysfunctional system
dysfunctional because of the
all the mess around getting
pcr tests all the different companies
charging absurd rates not providing a
service and so on and they've
responded not by improving the system
but by abandoning it entirely and i
think that's a pity i do think we need
pcr tests um because everybody always
said that lateral flow tests were never
what we call green light tests test to
say you're safe and therefore we can uh
you you can act as if you don't have the
virus what they do is they pick up
asymptomatic cases and very very
valuable in that regard i think it would
have been far preferable to keep pcr
tests but to improve the system and and
to do them through the nhs so i think it
is increasing risk i think it does limit
in fact it stops our ability to trace
different variants and increases the
probability of of infected people coming
into the country so i think it has
increased the risk quite frankly and i
think we should have improved the system
rather than by and large abandoning it
okay so
so you're against the dropping of the
pcr test do you think
that the
decision to offer booster jabs to
everyone uh is actually a good
step forward well rather than doing this
piecemeal let me give you my sense of
the overall direction of travel we
should have because
if you remember back to last year 21st
of september last year sage made a
recommendation that we need to put
protections in uh in place in order to
avoid the pandemic getting out of
control and the government ignored that
they ignored it for nearly two months
the pandemic got so far out of control
that as always happens if you wait and
things get out of control you have to
impose greater restrictions which is why
we had a non-christmas and such an awful
winter uh and spring on the 8th of
september this year um sage again made
the point that actually we're in real
danger we can't be certain but we're in
danger of things running out of control
and rather than having to put in place
severe restrictions later let's do
sensible things now and the good place
we're in largely due to the vaccine is
that in order to get things under
control if you combine the vaccine not
with stringent lockdown but with
moderate protections and support for
people then you can bring even the delta
variant under control and that's been
shown in a range of countries it's been
shown in israel it's been shown in
denmark it's been shown in singapore so
what i would do is not restrict the
public not lock down the public but
increase the protections for the public
and let's take just one very simple
example when we talk about safety we
often focus on the individual the
individual must get vaccinated it would
be far more effective i think to make
sure that environments are safe that the
pubs and the clubs and so on that we go
into have got proper coverage standards
so why don't we have a proper licensing
system exactly the way the same way that
we license kitchens to make sure that
they don't
um to keep us safe so protections not
restrictions protections and support
along with vaccine that will keep us
safe very briefly um there are nearly
six million people who either because
they couldn't be bothered or because
they are actively opposed to it have not
been vaccinated very briefly is there
any way that you can see to get those
people jabbed
yes first of all as you say most people
who are not vaccinated aren't vaccine
hesitant or anti-vax they simply haven't
got around to it so make it easier for
them by bringing vaccine stations into
schools into universities into
workplaces make sure that people can
have paid time off to get vaccinated so
make it easy bring the vaccine to the
people that's number one number two is
to give clear and consistent information
as to why vaccines are important and if
you spread a message implicitly or
explicitly that infections don't matter
then people are going to think why
should i get vaccinated and the third
and the most important is amongst those
who have doubts don't treat them as
fools don't treat them as the enemy
don't push them away don't push them
into the hands of the anti-vaxxers build
trust show respect listen to people
address their concerns um and as i say
win them over trust yeah absolutely
critical and that's one of the things
our government has forgotten build trust
don't distrust the public
professor reichert
professor riker thank you very much
indeed
thank you
now the new foreign secretary liz truss
has said that the decision to share
nuclear technology with australia shows
the uk's readiness to be hard-headed in
defending our interests
france is furious at being excluded from
the tripartite talks with washington and
canberra not to mention losing out on a
submarine contract worth some 47 billion
pounds
leon panetta has served as white house
chief of staff head of the cia and the
u.s defense secretary he told us that
the french should really be more
supportive more on that in a moment but
first i began by asking him for his
reaction to this week's admission that
one of america's last acts in
afghanistan a drone strike in kabul had
killed 10 innocent people
it's not good news uh i look uh
drone strikes are
weapons of war
uh and you have to
exercise tremendous
caution
when you're targeting
with a drone
as someone who's been involved involved
with drone operations as director of the
cia
i thought it was very important
to have
intelligence not only
uh using our surveillance capability but
also
using people on the ground spies on the
ground
to identify those targets and make sure
that
we had the right targets when we fired
uh in this instance it's pretty clear
that that kind of care was not exercised
and a terrible mistake has been made and
it does reflect badly i think on the the
approach
that was used to decide what target to
hit i know there was a tremendous amount
of confusion i know there was a
tremendous amount of pressure to try to
go after those that had killed our
marines
and killed others
but that's no excuse
for not developing accurate information
when it comes to targeting individuals
do you think that this kind of mistake
let's call it that
weakens the united states hand in its
foreign policy and its work to try to
extend its influence across the globe
well look at any anytime
this kind of mistake is made
uh
it uh it reflects badly
uh in terms of the methodology
of
applying
our technology to
targets on the ground
now you know having said that
we live in a very dangerous world
uh and we're dealing with a lot of
adversaries
whether it's russia whether it's china
whether it's iran whether it's north
korea
uh whether it's failed states in the
middle east whether it's terrorism
uh and uh
the fact is that we still are at war
with terrorism
i think the result in afghanistan is
that
we have a taliban
that will probably continue to provide
safe haven
uh to terrorists like al qaeda and isis
and haqqanis and others
and so we're going to have to
make sure that in dealing with that
threat to our national security
uh yes we're going to need the very best
intelligence we can get
on those targets to the extent that a
mistake was made here yes
it's something that
we have to worry about we have to
investigate as to what happened
and we have to make sure that it never
happens again
can i turn now to
wider issues of foreign policy
is it fair to say that the biden
administration's
foreign policy has just one overwhelming
priority
china
well there's no question that uh
china is a priority
but
i i'm not sure you can call it
the
only overwhelming priority we have
we're probably facing more flash points
in the world than we face since the end
of world war ii
because it isn't just china
uh it's also russia which has become
much more aggressive in their actions
particularly towards the united states
iran is continuing
to enrich fuel
and is getting closer to the capability
of having a nuclear weapon
north korea is now firing more missiles
and developing more nuclear weapons
and we are continuing to see terrorism
and we're continuing to see cyber
attacks which is the battlefield of the
future
so we're dealing with a lot of threats
and yes china is one of those
but the united states has to be capable
of being able to respond
to national security threats across the
board
and that means that we have to be strong
enough militarily and diplomatically to
be able to deal with those challenges
when
you were
the
chief of staff in the white house um
your administration was pretty clear on
china it
thought that the globalization and
economic growth would lead to greater
freedom
and a different relationship with china
and reform in china itself
it hasn't worked out that way has it
unfortunately uh it has not worked out
that way
and there's been a lot of mistakes along
the way
i think president obama was right when
he talked about rebalancing our force to
the pacific i was secretary of defense
when we made that decision
and it was important to do that
in order to make clear to china that yes
we will work with them we will have
dialogue with them we'll try to deal
with them economically and financially
as as we have
but at the same time
we are also going to protect our
national interests
when it comes to the pacific which means
that the south china sea
cannot
be an area
that limits the ability of shipping
and free trade
and freedom of the seas to be able to
take place
it means that we have to respect human
rights it means that we have to protect
taiwan
uh it means that we have to make sure
that the right thing is done with
regards to hong kong as well
uh so
yes
we can have that dialogue
but at the same time i think we have to
be prepared
in order to show china
that there are lines that they cannot
cross
is the pact signed this week between the
united states
the united kingdom and australia
to provide australia with
nuclear-powered submarines
uh
a preparation as you've just
talked about or is it as the chinese are
saying a provocation
i think it's about engagement and i
think it's about deterrence
i think that's that's the message that
they should get
uh
you know i
i think that the
the most important thing
that needs to be done
uh in dealing with china is to
strengthen our alliances
the one thing the chinese don't do very
well is have allies
uh that's not something that works well
for them same thing is true for russia
uh they don't like other countries
developing alliances that might limit
them uh in the decisions they make
and so i think the fact that uh we
announced this security partnership
and that we made clear
that we are going to be able to exchange
not only intelligence
but also
technologies uh and we're going to help
provide
nuclear-powered submarines to the
australians
so that they can have that capability
i think what that does is it sends a
message to china
that
we are not going to simply sit back
and allow china to have its way in the
pacific but there's a price to pay here
isn't there and that is in the terms of
america's own allies
the deal that you signed with the uk and
australia has made the french furious
the french foreign minister described it
as a stab in the back and the elysee
palace has recalled its ambassador to
the united states
this is a misstep isn't it
well you know i i'm i'm not sure of just
exactly what kind of conversations went
on
uh with regards to our allies france and
others as well
i would hope
that when this kind of partnership is
announced
that
our other allies would support that kind
of partnership because very frankly
the role of allies is to build
partnerships
and to be able to work together when it
comes to security
when it comes to
our economics when it comes to trade etc
that that's that's the heart and soul
of having allies let me just ask you
this though
that the french said that uh the this
behavior
looks like something that mr trump would
do isn't that the biggest insult that
anybody could level at a biden white
house
well
yeah and it's probably not accurate
because
i'm not sure that president trump
had the ability to develop
the kind of partnerships
that the biden administration developed
in this case the kind of strategic
partnership uh between the united
kingdom uh australia and the united
states uh that was not something that
trump was very interested in doing so
but you see my point
it is uh it's a criticism but i don't
think it's based on fact but you see my
point here that the biden
administration's about to go into cop
26.
it's meant to give us world give the
world's leadership it's meant to bring
people together but by its actions
uh the pulling out of afghanistan uh
this particular
thing with the french
that it is alienating potentially people
is going to need to help it do the deal
at cop 26 for example
uh you know look i i think president
biden has made clear
that the united states
uh
wants to exercise world leadership and
wants to work
with our allies in the world and
you know have mistakes been made
of course they've been made
but
overall
i think that
it's pretty clear that this president
understands the importance of countries
working together
in order to provide for our mutual
security
and
i i guess my you know it to some extent
look there there is a problem here
because uh after
watching trump a lot of our allies
basically were very distrustful of the
united states i understand that uh and
we're starting to operate on their own
and france is a good example of that
but i i also think that they should
recognize that
uh
we have a different president
who is interested
in trying to work with the rest of the
world
and
we will have our differences
we will make mistakes okay but in the
end if we're confronting common
adversaries as we are
in china and russia and elsewhere
then we damn well better start working
together
mr panetta thank you very much indeed
thank you
the view from the united states there
france has a very different take on the
new defense pact between the united
kingdom the united states and australia
the elysee palace has recalled its
ambassador from washington for the first
time since 1793.
i'm joined now by a more recent
representative of the french republic
gerard arnold
bienvenue uh you heard the interview
with mr panetta there and i suppose his
attitude could best be described um as
uh general greta rian
why isn't the france cheering for this
alliance between its two nato
allies
know good morning uh well first you you
have to understand that uh what was at
stake was for france was much more than
the contract
uh because
providing 12 summaries to australia was
for us a strategic choice uh we wanted
to build a strategic partnership
which would be
the pillar of our indo-pacific strategy
uh two french presidents uh were visited
recently australia you know it's 20
hours a flight from paris
but there were a lot of meetings uh our
navies were training together a few
weeks ago there were big training
between indian french and australian
navies uh and so suddenly uh not only we
we we lose an important contract
but a strategic partnership is thrown
away overnight
and and there is another partnership
which is created
announced at least and france is
excluded from the for from the
partnership
and also the i think the americans and
the australians have had
injuries uh insults to the injury uh
because suddenly we discover they've
been plotting in our back for weeks and
months uh we are allies you know it's
not a way of treating lies
but there's
there's absolutely no reason why uh the
united kingdom and the united states
can't be uh allies both with australia
and with france and also australia can
be an ally with us and we're with france
tell the truth here you lost out on a
commercial deal 4.7 billion is a lot of
money and you are just cross about it
well first on the
on the the figures you know really under
what you said 47 billion uh british
pounds i think to the french it was only
something like six or seven billions uh
because the rest was for buying american
uh weapon system and for building them
in in australia where you don't have
actually shipyards
uh so it was not you know well it was
not 50 billion british pounds taken from
the from the french you know really it
wasn't important but it was not that
critical uh so why it make such a big
fuss about it
no but there is the first and i insist
on that the first is political uh really
as i've said uh we have been undercut uh
in what we considered as a very
important political uh choice and we
have been undercut by our
closest allies in a sense uh the way it
has been done is amazing you know really
we were not consulted we were not warned
and basically uh uh we we were told uh
through the tv uh
think of it you know for months british
americans australians have been plotting
in our back basically saying ah we are
going to
contract
take
the french uh you don't behave this way
between allies again france has been the
first european country active in the
indo-pacific area you know right now you
have uh a craft career british aircraft
carrier there but our
career was there three years ago
all right well you're
you're making the case that this isn't
um what might look from london
uh like a fit of peak but explain one
thing which is a puzzle here in london
you withdrew ambassadors from canberra
and washington but not london
well i think you know we don't consider
that uh the uk has been uh really has
played a critical role uh as you know uh
the the a lot of the
so-called uk uh technology uh in the
nuclear field as for the nuclear
deterrence force uh is actually american
and depending on on on the americans uh
so we considered uh that uh the whole of
the uk in a sense was subsidiary uh that
the impulse was coming from canberra on
on one side and from washington on the
other one
is is that a not very diplomatic way of
saying that uh london isn't very
important in french calculations anymore
i really again i'm not a diplomat
anymore uh but uh i think our minister
foreign affairs has said that in the in
this history uh as we said in french uh
uh the uk has been the fifth wheel of of
of the carriage
uh
it seems that um the one thing that's
not in in much supply here is diplomacy
what was it very diplomatic uh for you
to tweet that the uk is now run by a
monty python
government well you know we're
announcing that we that the uk is going
back to imperial measures it's really
and so it will join uh myanmar and the
us you know it's it's frankly it's
amazing you know it makes uh you know
it's it's really i think for me it's
extremely funny
and again i'm not a diplomat anymore i
was an ambassador but i'm retired and
i'm using the the freedom of retirement
to to say what i believe
all right well
all right well let's let's leave for the
moment what our americans would say
uh uh would call a french dis of london
and let's just return to france itself
are we seriously here seeing the
beginnings of a return under president
macron to a kind of goalism uh an
independent french foreign policy
well so first i think again let's go
beyond the storm of the today's storm
and we had president obama which
really
was totally indifferent towards europe i
was ambassador at the time after that we
had
trump who was a style
towards europe and now you have a
president biden as you have said
yourself there was afghanistan and now
there is this story but frankly when
president biden came to europe in june
there was on the american side
absolutely uh no show of interest for a
real cooperation with the the europeans
the european union has ascended to
washington a long list of of potential
fields of cooperation and nothing came
out of of washington so i think it's
it's natural that today we raise the
question saying
basically europeans wake up basically
the americans are having pivoted so much
to asia to china as you have said okay
groupers don't the americans don't care
so much about europe you look ukraine
syria libya the sahel all of your
environment is in flames and the
americans are not there so that's reason
why president macro is saying maybe we
should have what he calls strategic
autonomy it's not anti-american it's
simply looking at what america is today
okay
thank you very much bye-bye
well that's it from us this week stay
with us for the take for analysis of
today's show with sky's deputy political
editor sam coates
[Music]
you